dynamic probability is my made-up
heading this there's no way that causes
dynamic probability but this is what it
is the boring eating of this would be
the probability trees but the time when
it's actually useful and valuable to use
probability trees is where as you
progress through a scenario a
multi-stage complicated event the
probability it changes its dynamic right
it doesn't just stay the same you roll
the dice it's always a since always
assist or its its static okay
the opposite is a dynamic situation
where as you do one thing it affects
what happens next in the next stage okay
this happens all the time
question 11 it gives us a kind of
contrived example but it's a it's easy
enough to understand and that's why it's
a useful place to start let's look at it
Alex and Jaya are playing in a tennis
tournament they'll play each other twice
and each has an equal chance of winning
the first game all right let's stop
there we can put this down a diagram
right away the whole point is that when
you have these dynamic probabilities
that's where probability trees really
get a chance to shine where even though
they take some time to draw right you
get repaid richly in that time because
it makes it so much easier understand
scoring so we've got two alternatives
Alex wins or Julia wins okay this is the
first game maybe you want to label this
as such
okay I always put my hitting's up the
top because in a probability tree a
column of events represents one single
thing happening but their different
alternate within that theme so they
already tell us there's an even chance
first game if Alex wins the first game
so now I'm on one branch right and not
the other if Alex wins the first game
his confidence increases and his
probability between the second game is
increased 0.55 so here we are of the top
ok we're considering if alex is one
still there are two alternatives Alex or
Julia
but now B odds are in his favor right so
we've got 0.55 up here which means that
it's complement surely a winning second
game of course is 0 for 5 excellent ok
however if he doesn't win the first game
he loses heart or how about you so that
is probability of winning the second
game is reduced to 1/4
okay 0.25 so I've got my same
alternatives
again ok so we think you have a
likelihood of human winning the second
game after losing the first game I
should have um made all of these events
down here are the second game and it's
dropped down to 0.25 so disappointed as
if I'm gonna win
Julia's clearly stronger okay which
means in the complement Julia weighting
twice now becomes zero point cool so now
for here even though you don't I don't
ask you to do this but it's going to be
useful to us in a second anyway there
are only four alternatives right I could
say the probability of Alex winning both
games right that's gonna be 0.5 times
0.55 which I do not know over the top of
my head I'm guessing it's 0.275 Sunfire
which we get by the factual like we just
multiply that across the probability of
Alex we in the first case
but and losing will be that looks like
0.225 yep the probability of an
experiment behind of winning is going to
be 0.5 x 1 j 5j a by the way for what
i'm at is here clearly right that's
0.125 yes and then the proto that you're
getting in clean sweep that'll be point
375 okay so no problems there we go I've
got all my options lined up and you can
see you could verify if you like that
when you add up all of these you're
gonna get your 1 just like you'd expect
okay all right excellent now they asked
us some questions find the probability
will actually just one question that
Alex wins exactly one game now the
benefit of course of actually writing a
SAS because you can see it's standing
there out in bright shining lights which
of the alternatives they're getting part
of the up the favorable outcomes right
here you go Alex wins one game here and
he wins one game here okay so you could
write it over here or down below if you
like the probability of Alex winning one
game once exactly looks to me like it's
0.35 35 percent simple start right like
I've said very contrived they've given
you all these options here but you can
see the whole point of it is that now
you have a probably trade and everything
is labeled it's so structured there's no
opportunity for you to miss something to
miss count it's all laid out for you
okay I think the big challenge in
probability questions is miss counting
theater that's all